Hello everybody, I'm so sorry.
I'm so... I'm so sorry.
I even got... I was home early too.
And then... I'm sorry guys.
Oh my god, I can't... I was like trying to find my phone.
I was like, where's my phone?
Where did my phone go?
So I went downstairs to the lobby to call my phone and then the Uber driver picked up and was like, yeah, you left your phone.
I'm like, what the fuck?
I left my phone.
I'm so sorry.
I went to get hotpot.
I'm sorry.
I wanted to eat nice.
I ate a $150 hotpot by myself and I just wanted to feel good.
I just... I just wanted to feel good.
And then I left my phone at the Uber.
It was... No, I had... I had Wagyu beef.
I had Wagyu beef with my hotpot.
And then I had beef balls and then I had pork.
No, it was a really nice hotpot.
It was... It was $150 Canadian.
It was a really nice hotpot, guys.
You don't understand.
Today's my cheat day, guys.
Today is also my cheat day.
Today is a cheat week, but I just... I just wanted to feel good.
And then I left my Uber.
Dude, the fucking Uber driver like ransomed, like held my phone hostage.
He was like, can you give me $20 for me to drive back to give you your phone?
And like, I'm desperate.
I was... I was fucking desperate at that point.
So I was like, okay.
Yeah, because like I need my phone.
That's my... It's my stream phone.
I need... I need to get another phone.
I need... I need to get another actual phone.
I need another like phone with a SIM card in it.
Like, I can't have one phone because like one... My main phone with my SIM card and everything is my streaming phone as well.
So I was like, oh my God, I need another phone with... I need a phone with a SIM card.
And then he was like, yeah.
And then he's like, I'm almost there.
I'm almost... I'm almost home.
I'm almost there.
And I was like, sweet.
And then, you know, 10 to 15 minutes passed.
He's like, yeah, I'm almost there.
And I'm like, what do you mean?
I've been waiting... He's like, we'll get you... I'll give you your phone.
Like, you come downstairs now.
And I was like, okay.
And then I went downstairs.
Where is he?
Where...
He wasn't there.
He wasn't there, guys.
Also, yeah, I just wanted to talk to my chat after getting my phone back.
I told Tengen.
Anyway, Tengen.
Tengen, you can come in.
It's time to chill.
Huge shout out, by the way.
Huge thank you to Payday 3 for the sponsor.
This is... Hey, Tengen.
Are you ready to chill with me?
I gave him the notes on what to say.
Are you ready?
You know what to say?
I said most of the things already.
Oh, you did?
You said most of the stuff?
Okay, now say the stuff again for me.
Hey, man.
I'm not part of...
Hey, I said I'd give you a cut.
I said...
Read the script, Tengen.
Read the script.
Yes, there is.
I barely gave you talking points.
But yeah, the obvious update.
Definitely the UI.
I like it better on the main screen as it was before.
Definitely very cool.
And you know what's cool?
47% on discount.
Steve, go grab the game right now.
Oh my god, but you got the game for free.
Yeah, shout out to Gokibird.
Yeah, I sent him... I got the game for free too, guys.
I have the game.
She gave me the next edition.
Yeah, I gave him the one year anniversary.
But yeah, anyway, guys.
So, Payday 3 actually went through an insane new update for the first year anniversary.
So, if you played Payday 3 before, it's gonna be very different now.
So, they have like... What was it?
They have new voice.
In-game voice, right?
They have new server browsers, new menu UI, and Halloween mask as well.
So, a lot of new stuff.
There's a new server browser.
So, it's more easy to find servers that you wanna find.
And then, there's also like... It just looks very new.
And there's a lot of new missions too, right, Tenjin?
I feel like you're... The reason why I got Tenjin is because I didn't wanna play by myself.
And like... And also, he has a lot of hours in Payday in general.
My brother does.
You said you have a lot as well, didn't you?
Well, how much do I have in Payday 2?
Hold on.
You have more than me.
I have... Okay, this account has 145.
Let's see my old account.
Wait, what do you mean old account?
That's your...
I have 1,100.
What the fuck?
Holy...
I've spent that much on Payday 2?
Oh my god!
Wait, that's a lot.
Too much.
Yeah, that's a lot.
That's why I dragged Tenjin in here.
Cause like, he knows what he's doing.
He's a goddamn veteran.
Yeah, but there's like a lot of new stuff now.
And you can get it now on like...
What is it?
It's available now on PC, Playstation 5, and Xbox Series.
And if you click on the link in the description and...
Or pinned on the comment, it really does help the stream a lot.
And it just leads you to Payday 3.
But yeah, anyway.
Alright, Tenjin.
What do we do?
Let's start a heist.
Also, Sound Guy, I upped the volume a little bit.
So let me know if it's better.
Yeah, it's on sale.
Yeah, only if you click my link will it tell you it's on sale.
Alright, let's try some...
Plan heist, yada yada.
Okay, we're not doing stealth.
What?
You don't believe in me?
No.
What?
You don't believe in me, Tenjin?
Excuse me.
90% of the time on Payday 2 heist time...
Yeah?
Where I stealth, it's usually solo.
It's never with anyone.
Okay, I'll break that streak, Tenjin.
I will break that streak.
It'll be different, trust me.
It'll be so different.
Trust me, Tenjin.
Well, hold on.
Is this the...
Wait, did I queue for...
What did you queue for?
Did I made it a fucking... hold on.
Wait, what did you do?
You already fucked...
Tenjin, we're sponsored.
You already fucked it up.
No, I was... I actually put like the hardest difficulty.
Oh, wait, no.
Is that normal?
Yeah, no.
I was queuing for normal.
You know what?
Let's pump it up by one.
Let's go harder.
Wait, you're trying to... Wait, what?
What do you mean?
What?
Why not?
This is stealth.
No, fuck you.
You don't even have a suppressor.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Do you have a suppressor?
Do you?
Yes, I do.
Yes, I'm looking at it right now.
I do have a suppressor.
Okay, let's try it then.
Yeah, I'm looking at it right now.
I do have a suppressor.
I do have it.
Trust me.
Alright.
Alright, alright.
I do have it.
What do you mean?
Okay, okay.
It's like right there.
Are you sure we're up for it though?
Yeah, yeah, I think we can do it.
We can do it.
Oh, I almost left the lobby.
Why are you talking in game?
I'm talking in game as well.
Oh, wait, that's a new update.
We're just showcasing the new update, guys.
We're just showcasing the new update.
Yeah, new voice over IP in the game.
Oh my god, yeah, you can play with random.
With the voice over IP.
Yeah.
Yeah, right here.
Yeah, see, we're already showing you guys the differences in the updates of the new Payday 3, guys.
Yeah, oh my god.
Wait, you're level 48?
Yeah, I've played this game for a while.
What?
Oh my god.
No, I only played Payday 2.
Like, no, like last year when the game dropped, I played it for a little while.
Wait, so what does a suppressor look like?
Like a suppressor.
Okay, I'm ready.
I see the pain.
Alright, is this a stealth mission?
It's any, stealth is an optional kind of thing.
Okay, alright, what do we do?
I don't know, this is a new mission.
Oh, oh wait.
Holy shit, a lady just bumped into me.
I need to, I need to turn down my mouse sensitivity.
I forgot how high this game is.
Alright.
Let me disable view IP.
Oh my god, wait, we have, alright, we got wolf and chains in here.
Do you believe, how do you put on a mask again?
Gee, we're not putting a mask here.
But like, wouldn't it be funny though?
What is it?
What's the point of, I have a sentry.
Oh wait, what?
Put it down, it would be so funny.
No, I have to put on the mask.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Is the FOV okay?
I can, I don't know.
I said, Tenjin was like, oh, put FOV at 100.
And I was like, I don't know.
It feels weird.
What are you doing?
Oh, just bros being bros, guys.
I just zoomed in on his face.
Just bros being bros, what's wrong with that?
No, it should be like this.
This is not Roblox.
What do you mean?
100 is at 9.
90 feels disgusting, not gonna lie.
It's too much.
Yeah.
But you literally told me to put it at max.
I was trying things out.
You fucking liar.
Wait, that's not you, I'm talking to Wolf.
I was getting a hotdog.
What FOV are y'all?
78.
78, okay.
I'm putting it on 70.
You fucking liar.
I was like, oh, what should I do for FOV, Tenjin?
And you're just like, oh, just do max.
That's what everybody does.
And I was like, really?
That's what everybody does?
Alright, what do we do, Tenjin?
What was our mission?
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, enter digital.
That's in front of us, right?
It should be, yes.
Yeah.
Scope out the lobby.
Hey, I'm walking in.
Is that really very low?
Okay, I'll do 78.
God, is this it?
We're not gonna be suspicious.
Okay.
Delphine?
Hello, concert.
Disable the metal detector.
Do I have guns on me?
Yes, we do.
We are a heister.
Wouldn't it be funny if I just walked through the metal detector?
It would be funny, yes.
It would be so funny.
Where can we get in?
It would be so...
I pressed E.
There's a bathroom.
I accidentally pressed E.
Oh, hey.
I don't know what that was.
Unavailable?
I can't jump because I'm not...
Okay.
Oh, hi, wolf.
We can't get in here.
Okay, we gotta...
Okay, you closed the door.
Alright, I'm doing it.
I'm ready.
You ready?
Let's go.
I'm venting.
Alright.
I don't know what E does.
I have, like, a phone with an I on it.
I don't know where I'm going.
I'm following you.
Like, seriously, I've never played this heist.
That's why we're experiencing it.
To celebrate first year anniversary.
Oh, I disabled the metal detector.
Wait.
Is it both?
Am I cutting both?
I'm cutting both.
We did it!
Wait, how do we get through?
I think our bots were supposed to get through.
I think one of us should have been in the metal detector.
One of us should have!
One of us!
One of us should have not put on the mask.
Yeah, one of us should definitely not put on the mask.
Oh, he saw you.
I'm watching.
Oh my god, what if I shoot him?
No, don't.
Why not?
That would be so funny.
What are you gonna do?
Oh my god!
No!
Why?
I'm just telling him to move.
What were you doing to that poor civilian?
What were you doing to him?
Nothing!
I'm gonna put him out of his misery.
Now he has trauma because of you!
Oh shit, that's a long-ass block there.
You know what?
Okay, no, he's fine.
See?
You okay, sir?
I don't think he's okay.
He's not even...
He's suing!
He's gonna sue!
Oh my god, look what you did!
You're gonna go to jail!
You're gonna go to jail for maximum life.
I saw what you did.
I'm gonna be a witness to this.
No, you're not in the witness protection program.
I know what you did.
No, you did not.
I saw what you did.
Hold on, is this a lobby?
This is a lobby.
Wait, I don't...
Wait.
Oh shit, it's the code.
Nevermind, it's coded.
Wait, what are you doing?
How did he not see us?
Don't worry about it.
He was literally right there!
Nah, he didn't see anything.
We all saw you, Daniel.
We all saw you.
He didn't see shit.
I know what you did last summer.
That's crazy.
The camera.
The camera is...
Stop looking this way, camera, please.
How do we make it stop?
Oh, the guy is coming up.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Get him too.
Come on.
Grab him.
Why not?
Because we'll have to answer a radio.
Then answer it.
I can answer radios.
No, there's a maximum amount of radios we can answer.
So we cannot kill every guard.
Oh shit, I have to read.
Wait, I need to up the game a little bit.
You go do the heist.
I'm upping the game volume.
I'm doing streamer things.
Right.
Okay, I upped the game a little bit.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Is it safe for me to head over?
Daniel, is it safe for me to head over, Daniel?
They almost fucked up.
There's a guard.
Oh my
god, he's so stupid.
Oh, she saw me.
Did he see you?
No, he just heard something.
That means he heard something.
Josh, why are you looking this way?
Just sprint over here.
Don't worry about it.
Sprint over here.
What if I just walk over?
Yeah, you're fine.
You're fine.
You fucker.
I'm gonna shoot the gun.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna shoot the gun right now.
You think I won?
You know I'm crazy enough to shoot the gun.
Pull book.
Oh, button.
Oh, what does it do?
Can you press that?
I don't know.
Is that the basement door code?
Is that it?
What is this?
I don't know.
I'm figuring out.
What does this button do?
Watch this.
Did you just... Did you just open our window?
Did you just open our window?
I can't see shit, you know.
Wouldn't it be funny if the guard was out there?
Did you just open our window?
No, no.
No, I didn't.
7-8-2-5.
Wait, how did you figure out the code?
How did you do it?
It's right there.
Where did you... No, I meant the save.
How did you crack the save?
Oh, um, you just move until it wiggles.
Oh, what?
Yeah, you just move it.
What if I... I'm gonna click it.
I'm gonna...
Yeah, click it, click it, click it.
I'm gonna click it.
Click.
See, you don't... He's dumb as shit.
Yeah, he is.
He is pretty fucking dumb.
I'm gonna check other rooms, okay?
Alright.
I'm right behind you.
See, I told you I could stealth.
Oh, oh, what are you gonna do?
What you gonna do?
What you gonna do when he finds out?
Oh, he's fucking stupid.
Oh, he is.
Okay, here, hold on.
Okay.
He'll be alert in a place.
He'll look at that sign on your right and just go here.
Where do I go?
Alright, come here, come here, come here, come here.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I did it.
Oh my god, I'm a professional.
This is why we got Tenjin here.
He makes it look so easy.
So when you watch this gameplay...
Oh fuck, that's the lobby.
You're gonna be like...
Oh shit, that's outside.
Now, now when you look at... you look at this gameplay and you're like, wow, it's just that easy?
Why don't we go upstairs?
That's the lobby.
I'm not going to the lobby.
Alright, guard is still there.
I'm rolling over.
Just print.
What if they hear me?
Just slide over.
Oh my god, this is... oh my god, how is this working?
Why won't they just hear... I like how our bots are just there.
They're in the toilet.
7, 8, 2, 5.
How does he not see you?
Just get on.
Come on.
What if he sees me?
He won't.
Oh my god, did we just... okay, goodbye chains and wolf.
You're just making sure...
Things are not going wrong.
Is everything going to be okay, Tenjin?
We need a red keycard.
Alright, the game is just that easy, guys.
What can I say?
The game is...
Surely it's easy.
Guys, it's just that easy.
Look at that.
Let me just scope out the place real quick.
Okay, wow, there's a lot of guards.
And a drone.
There is?
Wait, how are you scoping it out?
I'm looking through the camera.
You have a camera?
How did you use it?
I'm a hacker, man.
Oh, you're a hack?
Alright.
Is this a door?
This is a door.
Wait, this is...
That should wait.
Wait, wait, wait, the camera.
Shit.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh my god, never mind.
The camera spotted me.
Oh my god, look at him go.
We're loud.
Fuck, what did you do?
A camera was there.
Oh my god, Tenshin, what did you do?
Alright, now or never.
Can I shoot the drone?
Can we shoot the drone?
Yeah, shoot the drone.
Alright.
Get down, get down!
How do I make him get down?
I'm scared I'll shoot him.
Get down!
That's right, you're gonna need my human shield.
That's right.
That's right, I've got somebody.
Oh, you can pick that up now.
That's cool.
Alright.
Trade one hostage to delay.
Oh, we have a hostage!
F1 right here!
You have to go upstairs.
Are you serious?
Okay, no, I'm not.
I can't.
That's too much.
Tie him up.
Oh, you can do that now!
Alright, cool.
Get him, get him, get him!
Can we take him up?
Just tie him up.
No, just tie him up.
Oh, just tie him up?
Then you'll press F.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Wait, how come you killed so many people?
There's guards.
I'm gonna try and find more people.
Who has the red keycard?
I don't fucking know!
I'm gonna find more hostages!
Oh no, everything is locked up.
Everything is locked up, Tengen.
Look what you did.
This is your fault.
What?
This is your fault!
You're supposed to be a master!
Nah, I never played this mission.
Clueless.
This just...
What?
Oh, they're coming, they're coming, they're coming.
Oh no.
Where the fuck is the red?
Where the fuck is the red keycard?
I'm trying to find a red keycard everywhere.
Oh my god, no.
No, there's...
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, there's a vent.
Oh my god, we could have used this vent.
We could have...
We could have used this vent!
I don't think we can.
I don't think we can anymore.
That's fine.
Oh no, we got the SWAT.
Hey, it's just SWATs.
You have higher armor than me, so I'm sure you can handle this, right?
Thank you, DS.
Wait, there's another vent here.
What's the red?
We have a red keycard.
No, no, no.
Where the fuck is the red keycard?
I think it might be upstairs.
It's not.
I was scoping the whole area.
No, no, there's a way to go upstairs somehow.
Seriously?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's like an upstairs area.
It's blocked with keycard.
No, the vent area.
I feel like we need something to cut the vent.
I think we didn't have... Oh, I wish we could control our bots.
Oh my god, I wish we could control... Get out of here.
Get out.
Get out of here.
Taser, I'm being tased.
You're fine.
You're so healthy.
There's a lot of people.
Oh, there is.
There is.
Oh, I'm getting hit by random stuff now.
Wait, who's this?
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
I have purple armor.
It's fine.
What is this, Apex?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have purple armor.
I was wondering if I could like press these.
We're like walking around, but like...
Where do we go?
We need a red keycard.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Oh, you found it.
Alright, let's go.
It was like over here where I was.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I found it.
Alright, alright, alright.
There's a door right here.
QR code required.
Okay, never mind.
That's a QR code.
No, go up here.
Go up here, up here.
Wait, here.
Where are you?
Right here, right here, right here.
Oh, where?
Wait, how did they get up here?
They don't have a red keycard.
Who knows?
Oh my god, shut down SINs.
What the fuck is this?
Is this SINs?
Oh, this is, this is, this is.
Okay, okay.
I picked something up.
This is... Oh, it's armor repair.
Oh, I can swap the camera.
Okay, nice.
This is like...
You're looking at the camera.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, we can just stay here.
How did he get there?
We could've stealthed this.
That's all I'm saying.
We could've.
We could've stealthed this.
Wait,
what?
Cooling system?
Oh, I got you guys.
Um...
It always has.
Yeah, I'm sure.
Like, I know.
I know.
I know there is.
I'm fucking...
I'm fucking Isaac Newton.
Invent the dash shit.
I can't believe gravity was discovered today, guys.
I can't believe I discovered gravity.
Whoa.
Holy shit.
Okay, Trey.
Get over here.
You go fucking do your thing.
What other stuff do we need to...
Wait, there's something over there that I have to do.
It's at 30 meters.
I'm right here.
I'm defending it.
How do we...
How do we, like, get police hostages again?
I think you need a skill for police hostages.
God damn it.
My skills right now is just full stealth build right now.
Do I have to do this again?
No, you're just defending it so the cops don't meddle with it.
I have a sentry that's guarding this, so...
God damn it.
If I could go back in time, I would kill Isaac Newton so he wouldn't invent gravity.
Yeah, we could have had creative mode, man.
I know.
We could have been...
We could have no clip mode.
We could have been no clipping.
We could have no clip to Mars at this point.
People were always like, If I could time travel, I would kill this specific person that did all this stuff.
But I'd be like, no, I'm gonna kill Isaac Newton.
Alright, I'm disabling the sins.
If we had...
Just think about how much Isaac Newton has robbed us.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, there they are.
Wait, how do I get rid of this guy?
The guy with the shield?
I'm gonna run up to him and then...
I'm calling in my overkill weapon.
Oh, shit!
He doesn't like it when I... He doesn't like...
Oh, police assaulted.
This is police brutality, my man.
Oh my god, get down!
Get down!
Wait, oh my god, wait.
He has a different... He has a different outfit.
He's a special unit.
What makes him so special?
He electrocutes your nipples.
Oh, shit.
Does it feel good?
I wouldn't know that.
Why don't you know that?
I thought you were into that.
What do you know about me?
What is that?
Woah, woah.
Is the game okay, sound guy?
Oh, shit.
Is the game okay?
Is the music not too loud?
Oh, the music is good.
I love the music.
You know what?
I'll increase the music.
This game is a soundtrack, by the way.
Yeah, the music soundtrack is insane.
That guy has a bomb.
Wait, where?
Where?
Throwing knife!
You have a throwing knife?
Yeah, I do.
Oh, shit!
I shot the spikes.
I might be bleeding out of my ass right now.
I'm not doing so well.
I think I might need to see a doctor.
I think taking fall damage might have landed on my head.
Wait, does this need a keycard?
I might have a concussion.
Not gonna lie.
You dropped yourself when you were young.
No, I forgot the real world had fall damage.
I played too many video games.
I need a keycard.
Get over here.
Wait, where?
Where?
Over here?
Over here.
Over where I am.
Oh, my god.
Okay, there's a lot of people in front of me.
I'm shooting them through the walls.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm refilling my health.
Nice.
The police dropped some HP.
Alright.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
Nice.
Thank god.
I'm coming over.
Don't worry.
Righto.
Oh, there's so much ammo.
Alright.
How do I get up there?
How did you get up there?
There's a stair.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Have you taken one?
No.
I took an Uber.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure you've never.
Hey, I'm here.
Okay, guys.
I'll hack the computer.
I'll turn the valve.
Wait, is there friendly fire?
With a grenade, I think.
Okay.
Did you get hurt?
No.
Okay.
I tested.
There's friendly fire.
Overkill weapons ready when you are.
Are we defending?
Okay, yeah, we are.
We're just defending.
Oh, ender.
Private data off our server for hooks.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay, nice.
We're okay.
We don't have any hostages.
I'm tempted to go upstairs just to grab the hostage.
Like grab a civilian out in the wilds?
Yeah.
You know what?
I'm gonna do it.
You're doing it.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, you can't judge me.
I wasn't.
That's new.
No, that's new.
Legit, that's new.
I've never seen that.
That is new.
You saw me get electrocuted just to...
I...
No, the objective is right there.
Oh, no, no, no.
Okay, okay.
We can't even go back upstairs.
They locked us down.
Oh, they locked us down?
Yeah, they locked us down.
Sins.
Oh, no.
There's another...
They're deploying what?
They got cloakers.
Oh, it's cloakers!
Oh, cloakers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You'll have fun with them.
Oh, yeah.
I'll be right next to you.
So, we're gonna get involved together by the cloakers.
No, he attacks one.
He only attacks one?
Yep.
One by one.
Wait, that's not fair.
What do you mean?
Find and verify the correct servers.
We're fucked.
Wait, what do you mean?
What does that even mean?
What does that mean?
Dejan, what does that mean?
I've never played this mission.
Dejan, what does it mean?
Oh, my God.
Oh, everything is going wrong right now.
Wait, there's drones?
Yeah, that's new.
Oh, my God.
They sent in the drones.
You know, they're serious.
They're so serious.
Okay, we gotta...
Oh, that's the drone guy.
Hold on.
Let me kill him.
Find and verify.
Where the fuck do we verify?
Where the fuck?
Where's the verification?
Did they send the verification code to my phone?
Guys, and you think my phone has the verification code?
Is that what it means?
Okay, got him.
Oh, fucking hell.
Did you get a shot?
Oh, my God.
I almost ran into the other one, too.
Trying to figure out where the verification code is.
Everything is...
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Yeah, is that the right one?
I don't know.
Oh, God.
This big oil again.
Okay, I found... Where do we bring it?
I have no clue.
Oh, right there.
Where's the... Okay, okay, I got it.
I'm heading over.
Oh, yes, he's over there.
I forgot they're literally jump scares here.
Die.
You like roulettes?
They're back.
Get down.
That fucking karate kick was insane.
Did we get all the...
Did we get all of them?
I don't know.
What am I...
We found correct ones.
Okay, I need an armor.
Shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I have no armor.
I only have one.
I only brought one of the servers, so that means there's two more.
Yeah.
I have no idea.
Or three.
Oh, one of them is correct.
One of them is correct.
I'm low.
I'm low as shit.
Alright, I got one server here.
I'm tazed.
But we're got you.
No longer tazed.
Trying to find the last server.
Where's the last server?
Oh, I found a server.
I found a server.
I'm picking it up.
I'm heading over.
This is not the right server.
Oh, my God.
You are 1 HP, dude.
I am.
I need health or armors or whatever.
How do we test it to see if it's the right server?
Just like wait.
Oh, I'm decrypting.
I'm decrypting.
It's okay.
Our boss got this.
I got you.
Oh, I don't know.
I think I'm better at this than you.
I already found 2 out of 3 servers.
Keep fighting it.
I don't have armors to go around.
Okay, but where?
Where are the other ones?
I've called in a killstreak weapon.
If you want to grab it, just grab it.
Okay, there are like 200 police officers here.
Their family is not...
Oh, wait.
Hey, there's armor.
Their families are not...
Their families are going to receive a nice payout.
I'm running.
I'm running to find one more server.
Oh, there's one.
There's one right here.
Picking it up.
I don't know if it's the right one because it's the same one where I picked up the other server.
Okay.
Wait, what?
They're not...
They're not throwing this...
Wait, there's heals.
Armors.
Oh my god, there's heals.
Thank you, chains.
Oh, thank god.
Wait, where did the server...
Where did it go?
I picked up a server and it disappeared.
Again?
Oh, hey.
Chains, help me, man.
No, that's the wrong one.
That's the wrong one.
It's Mark.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I picked up a server and then it disappeared.
Found a server.
Oh, that was the one I was trying to pick up.
That poor... That guy did not know what was going on.
Fucking bot.
I was so confused.
I have another one if it doesn't work.
Alright, here.
I got this one here.
Alright, put it in.
Alright, I got another one too right here.
Fixing my sentry.
Oh, is this the gun you found?
Oh, I got it.
Nah, I called it in.
Okay, I'm gonna bring this other server if it works.
Does it work or nah?
One does not.
Okay, get that one.
Okay, here.
I got this one.
There's one more server here.
Holy shit.
Remember when you were like, oh, I'm gonna make sure that they're gonna come after you.
What happened to that?
I have another server.
Does it not work?
Wait,
this is a sniper.
How many servers?
Yeah, it shoots through walls.
Oh, it shoots through walls?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, watch this.
I'm gonna make sure...
Oh my god.
Behind you.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait, wait.
I'm gonna try to shoot through walls right here.
Throwing knives.
Oh my god, it works.
Oh my god, it actually shoots.
Okay, that's not the server.
Okay, I have one more server that will work, but I need you to bring me...
Oh, wait, wait.
Okay, never mind.
I can walk through this.
You're fine.
I can do this.
Okay, there's one more right here.
You have bigger armor than me, so...
Yeah, purple armor.
No worry.
Yeah.
Alright, I got it.
I found it right here.
Boom.
This has to be it.
That's literally the last server.
Wait.
Oh my god, that's so cool.
Wrong.
This is so cool.
I can literally, like, shoot from here.
Call yours.
Wait, I can call it?
Which one is it?
What number is it?
Press Z.
It's Z?
I don't have a Z.
You don't have a Z?
Wait, I do.
Did you call it in?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know where does it come from.
It's marked with an atomic bomb.
Like, a bomb.
Like, there, there.
There, I'm pinging.
I'm pinging.
Wait, I think because I called it, the gun disappeared.
Oh no, it's right there.
I pinged it.
No, no, no, the gun I picked from you.
Oh, here, here, here.
Follow me, follow me.
Do we get it?
Oh, we got it, we got it, we got it!
Plant explosives!
Yeah, yeah, I got it, I got it.
Here, grab this.
Okay, okay, yeah.
There's your gun.
Alright.
Okay, I get it.
Oh!
I remember now!
Time to get out.
Got the server.
Ams heavy.
It's okay, I got you.
I'm Demoman!
You're Demoman.
I am Demoman.
Oh, Elmer's Toast.
Don't worry, I got you.
Get him!
Boom!
Demoman.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Did you plant it?
Oh, no, you just grab the explosive here?
I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you have to grab it.
Fuck that guy, he's taking the drones.
Boom.
Okay, that's a little overkill.
But that's okay.
Boom.
It's called an overkill weapon for a reason.
Dude, the drones are shooting my ass off.
You don't have armor.
I don't.
Hold on, there's more weapons.
There's more armor back here.
I'll grab it.
Alright, I took the last armor.
Thanks.
Don't pay attention, I'm armored up.
Okay, you have the grenade launcher, yes?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
How the fuck do we get there?
We have to go.
Where even are you?
Where the Sins is.
Okay, I'm heading over.
Okay, I need to reload.
God, this song is so good.
Jesus, how long do I take to reload this?
I feel like I'm reloading for 20 years.
I need one more explosive, is that you?
Yeah, that's me, that's me, that's me.
Alright, Demoman.
I threw away the Demo gun.
Take cover.
7, 6, 5, 4, 3, I don't know, say hi to it.
Okay.
Don't say hi to it.
Alright.
Good to know.
I don't have armor anymore.
Well...
Oh my god, this game is so realistic, guys.
I think it's a bad idea, you should have not made me...
Our HP is so bad.
Why did you...
We don't have armors.
Why did you do this?
You're so lucky I found out I actually have armor.
Oh shit, I can do that?
How do I wear...
Oh shit!
How do I wear my armor?
Oh, I can't because I have no armor to wear.
You can.
Oh, I can?
No armor to wear.
Yeah, because I have no more armor.
Oh shit, do you have a grenade?
A grenade would be nice right now.
I just used my last one.
Oh, propane.
Oh my god, I wish our bots had armor.
I wish...
It's a berserker!
Jinx, turn around, Jinx!
Oh, this is so bad.
This is so bad.
Die, dozer.
Okay, he's dead.
Ah, fuck, you know what?
Explosive tank!
I'm just gonna say this is Tengen's fault.
I would've had full HP.
He could've easily been like, oh yeah, don't do that.
Don't do that.
Guys, guys, now you know.
Now you know, guys.
Now we're here to tell you.
Fuck around.
Fuck around and found out.
Oh, I definitely fucked around.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait, I can rez you!
Get knocked, get knocked, get knocked!
Okay, hold on.
Grab the server.
Trust me.
We'll go out in a bang.
I got you!
Get the server.
Wait, get the server?
Which one?
Oh, this one.
I got server, I got server, I got server.
You ever need...
No, I...
Oh wait, I do!
I got...
Oh my god.
Oh, our guy's here!
Our guy's here!
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
I'm scared!
How do I?
I'm stuck!
We're out.
Okay.
Oh, we're out.
Oh god, we're out.
Oh my god, we did it.
Oh my god.
Oh, we're rich!
Look at that!
Oh, we got so many rewards!
Hell yeah.
Oh my god, not even close.
Look at that, we got paid the same amount of money.
Hell yeah, I'm sure we are.
We're supposed to.
What happened to your secondary accuracy?
All I'm saying is that stats don't matter because we're paid the same amount.
We're paid the...
Does it really matter when we both get paid the same amount of money?
That's all I'm saying.
Does it really?
But yeah!
Hope you guys have been enjoying so far.
If you guys want to support the stream, please feel free to click on the link.
On my chat.
Pin on my chat and my description.
It helps a lot.
Tension carried?
I was...
Tension didn't even know where the red card was.
I don't know.
Let's see.
Boys in Blue, Fear and Greed, Houston Breakout.
Which one do you want to play?
What can I buy?
Do a new mission.
What's a good gun to have, Chat?
Chat, what gun should I get?
What's a good gun to have?
Let's go loud.
I'm gonna go loud and blow it out.
Get a silencer?
Wait.
Oh my god, if I could get the...
The Bull Kick 500.
Wait, that looks cool.
Do I even have a silencer?
Do I...
Oh wait, I should buy an armor bag, actually.
Yeah.
Okay, there's three missions.
Which one do you want?
New.
Boys in Blue, Houston Breakout, Fear and Greed.
Which one do you want?
This looks cool, I'm gonna buy this.
Blue.
Wait, no, no, no.
New.
Anything that's new.
Everything is new.
Oh.
People said Boys in Blue is fun.
Boys in Blue.
Alright.
By people, I mean one guy.
One guy.
One guy told me.
Hey, they're people.
They are people.
They're the people.
They are the people.
Wait, wait, guys, before I do.
Guys, which one lets me take police officers as hostage?
No!
Oh, thank God, okay.
Okay, guys, which one lets me take police officers hostage?
That's like the main one.
The Voices of Many.
That sounds like a fucking...
That doesn't sound real.
Wait, which specialist is this?
CQC Specialist, I think.
I wanna take police officers hostage.
Forced Friendship.
Oh, I like that.
But which one is it?
Is it Grifter?
There's Grifter.
Yeah, guys, I'm a Grifter.
Which one?
Oh, Manipulator.
Manipulator?
Okay, Manipulator.
Okay, oh, I have to research?
How do you research, Tengen?
Just research and play a game.
Okay, I'm researching.
Alright, I'll put...
Let's see, I'm gonna put it on Medic for now just because I can't do anything with it.
Oh, I can deploy two additional charges?
Oh, nice.
I'm gonna queue for the next mission.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, I'm trying to be useful.
I am trying to be useful right now.
You are?
Now I am!
Okay, now I'm...
Okay, Mr. Fucking Smartass.
I want to dress...
I want to put on a new mask, too.
Actually, you know what I'm gonna put?
That suit.
Oh my god, this looks like I'm on...
Yeah!
Alright, let's see.
I want to put on... I'm on vacation.
I'm gonna be on vacation and then...
Wait, can you change your melee weapons?
In Payday 2, you could.
I know, I don't know if you can for this one.
Wait, I look like I'm on vacation right now.
Alright, I'm ready.
Um, actually...
Actually...
Hey man, you gotta make your clothes work in a mission, you know?
Just saying.
I mean, I look like I blend in right now.
I look like I blend in.
I'm on vacation, I'm here on a break.
From my 9 to 5.
It's been a long day.
I almost lost my phone at the Uber.
Things haven't been going so well.
Guys...
Why does it take so long to prepare heists?
It's like literally us two.
That's one of the thing...
That's one of the thing that I think that has been pointed out.
On a thing.
Basically...
A lot of people find it kind of...
Discomforting and you have to like...
Prepare for the heist kind of thing like that.
Well, there's the beta version of it.
Like where you can host it on your own.
Like in Payday 2.
But for now, it's only available to play on your own for now.
But I'm pretty sure if things are right and give a lot of feedback to it...
You know...
They'll actually put that in.
You know, it's like you can host it on the server as of your own.
Just like Payday 2.
So make it seamless.
Oh, I see.
Oh, that makes sense.
Wait, am I using...
Wait, no ass...
Oh, I didn't...
How do I custom...
Oh, I need to like add stuff to my gun.
Can I mod my gun?
You gotta level up your gun.
Okay.
I don't have anything on my gun.
Yeah, I don't have anything on it.
You have a preset gun.
I'm ready.
I got my medic bag.
I have a medic bag too.
Wait, the gold that a cop stole from Vlaad is held in a police depot.
The depot out in the...
Okay, I guess we'll never know.
I guess I'll never know the lore.
Whoa, fuck reading I guess.
We'll never know.
It just skipped on its own.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Dude, what are you wearing?
What am I wearing?
I'm on vacation.
How did you say hi?
Middle mouse.
Middle mouse?
I'm inspecting my hands.
I need ammo.
Do you wanna see my hands?
Do you wanna see it?
Whoa, look at my hands.
Follow me, guys.
Wait, what are we supposed to do?
Get inside the station?
I mean, that's easy.
We just walk in.
We're supposed to raid a police station.
Hey guys, what happens if I do this?
Pick up donuts.
I'm picking up donuts.
I got donuts.
I stole donuts.
We're out.
You stole the fucking donuts?
I stole donuts.
I'm outta here.
Holy shit.
That's right.
That was the heist.
That was donuts!
That's right.
What you gonna do, huh?
Cougher.
What you gonna do?
Yeah, that's right.
You saw it.
Did you try to go in?
You fucking tried to go inside?
No, I played the speaker.
He's looking at the speaker.
Don't worry.
They won't know.
How would they know?
There's a camera right behind you.
There's a camera right behind...
Okay.
Okay, goodbye.
Bro, he saw you.
No, he didn't.
What you talking about?
He saw you!
He didn't catch you!
No, he don't know where I am.
What you talking about?
No, he didn't catch you!
You fucking...
Oh, thank God.
How would he know?
He wasn't supposed to be in the middle.
I'm placing my donuts.
Oh, and you were like...
Oh, Doki.
You're not gonna be able to do self-missions.
I'm not stealth like this.
Oh, you won't be able to...
You won't be able to do self-missions.
Fuck, he gets alerted instantly.
No, get over here.
I know, I'm trying to get the hostages.
You have to witness this.
Okay, I'm witnessing.
What did you do?
I'm placing my donuts.
Oh, my God.
We're so fast now.
Holy shit, that's a buff.
Oh, my God, let's go.
We're so fast with the power of donuts.
Get to the car depot.
Where is the car depot?
We need to get the car impound.
Holy shit.
Oh, get to the car depot.
Where is the car depot?
I ran out of ties.
You ran out of ties?
Yeah.
There's a sniper.
He's aimed at you.
He's gonna take the shot.
I think that laser...
I think that laser is not supposed to be painting at me.
Holy shit, I'm picking up money.
Holy shit, I just lost a whole chunk.
Yeah, I wonder how.
I wonder who fucking shot you.
Oh, my God, this takes forever to reload.
I'm ready.
Where is the car depot?
I don't fucking know.
I'm following you.
Surveillance room.
We don't need that.
Over here.
Okay.
Oh, right here.
I got him.
I did it.
Explosives.
Are we gonna talk to the explosive again?
Yeah, right here.
I'm not talking to the explosive.
I got one of them.
Why not?
Coward.
Pussy.
There's one more.
I thought it was you.
I have two bombs.
Okay.
Wow, Lonelywood did this stealthily.
Damn.
Man, that's crazy, isn't it?
I couldn't care less.
I just wanna shoot things.
He just went into your donut.
That's it.
Wait, this is the same area.
Oh my god, wait, unless...
Don't worry, guys.
Okay, it doesn't work.
Wait, unless...
Guys...
What did you do?
Nothing.
Nothing?
Like no big deal?
Nothing is going on.
Wait, how do we...
We gotta figure out how to...
Wait, why are you not going inside?
I'm opening it.
Oh, we have to defend this, okay.
Yeah, I'm carrying money as well.
I figured out what the stealth version was for this.
What?
There's like a vent and you have to figure out...
I don't know.
You have to go through the vent or some shit.
Oh, armor.
Do we have to hostage?
No, it's fine.
I have so many hostages.
I'm gonna go for it.
I'm gonna find them.
Where are they?
There was a lot of hostages I took upstairs.
Yeah.
I'm trying to...
Oh, I'm lost.
I'm so lost.
Confidential police files?
Where is that?
I knew it.
Get over there.
There's a lieutenant.
That's right.
Go over there right now.
At the captain's room.
Alright, I got several hostages.
Alright, and then...
Follow me.
Get up.
Get over here.
I need you to be in a more hostage situation.
How did you go upstairs?
Oh, it's right here.
Come on.
Get over here.
Life doesn't matter.
That's right.
I can do this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You scared?
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
I can shoot you right now.
I can shoot you in the toes right now.
I got a money bag.
I have one of them here.
Alright, now get down.
Oh, shit!
Who the fuck is she?
Okay, we have several hostages too.
We gotta make sure we don't accidentally shoot them up here.
Don't.
Oh, I'm stuck on the desk.
What are you doing, Tengen?
Huh?
I'm grabbing a cable.
Don't you dare take our hostages.
Don't you take our hostages.
Oh, we killed one of them.
It wasn't me.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
How would I shoot the floor?
I'm literally aiming at the level.
It wasn't me.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
Your lives never mattered.
Okay.
Okay, if they mattered, what was their name?
What was their name, Tengen?
Chat, what was his name?
Does his life really matter?
If it matters, you would know his name.
What is his name?
Jackie.
Exactly.
That's right.
Checkmate.
You don't know his name.
I can wake up.
Die.
There's money here.
What do I do with the money?
Yeah, grab the money.
Yeah, but where do we put the money?
Did you set the generator?
Oh, you set the generator!
I'm doing the side objective.
What the fuck are you doing the side objective for?
Extra money.
Oh my god.
Is $300,000 not enough for you?
No.
Okay, I know it's enough.
Because I know what the conversion rate is.
Oh, you know the conversion rate?
Oh, surely you do.
I've explained to you so many damn times.
I know how much 10 American dollars can get you in Indonesia.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Oh my god, I need help.
Oh my god.
Extra cash from Vlad.
Can never go wrong.
Vlad is my man.
What are you doing?
What is he doing?
Wait, why is he running away?
Why is the blue guy running away?
That's the hostage you traded.
Oh!
Oh, sorry.
I almost killed the extra hostage.
I might have like...
Knocked him with my gun.
Because I didn't know.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
Sure.
I feel very safe.
You got the money?
No.
Where's the other money?
I don't fucking know.
I've just been shooting the cops.
I've been shooting the popos.
Grab the armor.
Oh, yeah.
I got it.
Okay, that hostage was in blue.
So I thought he was the police.
It's understandable.
He's blue.
So then it makes me want to shoot him.
End game.
End game, guys.
I was running for him for a good three seconds.
He was literally...
What the fuck is he anyways?
I can't recall.
He was sticking on a wall like Spiderman.
He just came out of nowhere.
He literally like dived down.
I don't know.
I called in my gun.
Where does it come in?
It depends on where yours at.
I think it's here.
The heli's here.
Is that my gun or yours?
I literally just called it.
I called a demo man.
Oh, this is your gun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My demo man gun.
It's demo man time.
I can't call my gun.
Wait, why not?
He's refueling.
Oh no.
Okay, we gotta defend it.
I'm ready.
Oh, there's a sniper!
I don't think my grenade launcher can get up there.
Right.
I got one, I got one.
Oh, there's more coming over here.
Don't worry, I've got...
Wait, where's my...
Wait, what's my...
Oh, where did my demo man gun go?
Oh, it's over there.
You dropped it.
I got it, don't worry.
Fume.
You can sabotage your ship now?
Yeah, they can.
No, like your equipment and stuff.
Oh, wait, they took it?
They took our equipment?
Yeah, the armor.
Oh my god, you think our taxpayers don't pay enough armor already?
I know.
Steal the gold.
Time for stealing.
Oh, I'm ready.
Oh, that's a cool animation.
Did you drill it?
Yeah, I'm drilling it.
Okay.
Looking through the police report.
I'm destroying evidence, guys.
I'm destroying evidence.
I'm picking up rare elements right now.
Oh, there's ammo.
There's armor.
Oh, there's more evidence.
Oh, cocaine.
Hell yeah.
Hey man, I said what it is.
I said what it is.
And I stand corrected.
Look man, you just got the right stuff.
And I'm... I don't know.
I got stuff.
What did you get?
Is it gonna disappear?
Is this item gonna disappear when I turn around?
What's gonna happen?
No, it's not.
Oh my god, it's so heavy.
What is this?
Is this the right shit?
Are we supposed to be here?
I don't know.
I'm just doing what you're doing.
I don't think so either.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm pretty sure.
Why are you following me?
Because you have level 40.
You have a thousand hours of baiting.
What do you mean?
I literally have never played this mission.
Don't worry, I got you.
I'm still putting in that thing that you put last time.
What happened to my armor?
What did I do?
Don't worry, you'll be fine.
Alright, I put it all in the little cubby hole.
Are you still getting harassed?
Yes.
Oh shit.
Grab more of the bag.
There's an extra cache upstairs.
Oh, I don't have any armor.
Is there extra armor?
Oh!
Guys, I need help!
You have armor?
I'm reloading!
You can grab that.
No, I can't wear it!
No!
Oh shit.
Guys, I picked the wrong pistol.
Guys, please.
20 seconds, guys.
You can't refill this?
I can't!
I can only pick it up!
That's all I can do!
Oh, I can take this though.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, please have mercy on me.
Yeah, I can't refill it.
Where are you supposed to prepare the gateway?
Is it on the left side?
I'm drilling through it, but there's a lot of snipers.
I'm right behind you.
Oh, it's jammed.
I'm fixing it!
I'm using my hammer!
I'm hammering it!
Okay, I'm hammering.
Is that how you...
Guys, is this historically accurate?
Is this historically accurate?
The drills always have been pretty shit.
So...
We're playing Minecraft right now.
Makes me wonder if we were supposed to put it there.
I'm gonna put it there just to keep it safe.
Just so they don't grab it.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking too.
And this is like 20 seconds left.
Oh, there's more snipers up top.
Ah!
Okay, that was not a sniper.
That was not a sniper.
Oh my god.
He's fucking shaking.
Okay, we gotta wait.
Why is it so slow?
What's it gonna do?
Fucking break the car in half?
Like, what is this gonna do?
It could.
There's no way.
It could be like 0.5 faster and the car will be okay.
The car will be okay if it was 0.5 faster.
You can't guarantee that.
Yes, I can.
It's called gravity.
Yeah, but Isaac Newton fucking invented that shit.
Oh yeah, Isaac Newton fucking hates me.
I hate that bitch.
I know where he's buried.
This is why people don't know where he's buried, guys.
I think they know.
I was gonna desecrate that tree.
It wasn't in the nose.
I was gonna 5-4 shoot dudes.
End game!
End game, guys.
I heard he was an asshole back then.
He deserved it.
I think everyone was pretty much an asshole back then.
No, no.
But Isaac Newton, he was a special kind of asshole.
Oh!
Dozer!
Oh, I heard you, Phil.
Oh, fuck me.
My armor's jumped off.
Oh my god, he's taunting!
Oh my god, look at him!
He's like, yeah, you wanna get me?
You got me there?
Is he dead?
He's dead.
I did it, guys.
Wait, we unlocked them.
Can I?
Oh, we have to go back inside.
We have to go back inside.
Smoke grenade!
Alright, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over.
I've smoked it.
I'm running over.
Holy shit.
It's like...
Upstairs is upstairs.
Wait, how do I go upstairs?
Oh, it's right here.
I'm gonna eat some donuts.
Donuts.
Wait, where is it?
You'll need to open the security plow through it.
What?
Oh, fuck, it's in the safe, isn't it?
Wait, I can do it too.
Okay, I give up.
I give up.
It's too difficult.
Got it.
Got the key, got the money, got the money.
Bam, bam, bam.
Boom.
Shit, there's a lot of people.
Smoke grenade.
Okay, that works.
Oh, it takes all of us!
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
Wait, how could they see stuff?
How could they see stuff too?
Guys, is there fall damage for this?
Oh, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'll open the gate, start the car.
Okay.
I'm in the car.
Refilling HP.
Oh!
No!
Help!
Okay, okay.
Fuck this box 7.
My ass right there.
Secure the loot.
Move the loot.
That was the scariest shit I've ever seen.
Alright, I got the gold too.
Fuck.
It's so heavy.
Just gonna throw it out farther away.
Okay.
I wish our bots could carry the gold.
I think they can.
Someone took our shit!
Wait, what?
How?
Hey, give us more money.
Give him his money.
Yes.
I broke my armor.
Oh no.
Trying to head over right now.
Okay, I can go.
I can go.
Oh, I can't go.
I can't go anymore.
I can't go.
Alright, I'm running.
I'm running.
I'm fucking walking.
Oh!
Right there.
I got him.
Keep throwing shit.
I got one of them.
I need a second one.
We have a system.
I'm not seeing a sniper shoot one bullet.
The sniper shot me once and I fucking died, guys.
I don't know.
I actually got knocked down.
Wait, what's that?
Oh!
Oh my god, there was a drone.
Okay.
Alright.
I've got four more.
Oh no, the drone is evil.
Holy shit!
Please live!
I'll throw a smoke grenade.
Okay.
Okay, I have more.
I have more.
Oh!
No!
We want all of it!
You don't understand, ma'am!
We want everything!
Okay.
Oh, I see your special powder.
I picked it up.
You picked it up?
Yeah.
We got the special powder.
Alright.
Happy powder.
Okay.
Oh, level 7.
Level 8.
Oh my god.
We leveled up so fast.
I'm already level 10.
Wait, how much did you...
Oh, sorry.
I shot... I might have shot one.
I don't understand.
Why would we lose money for shooting a civilian?
Hey, man, we gotta pay for degrees.
Like...
Yeah, but we shot so many cops.
So wouldn't it be like...
The government pays for them.
How come I don't see your stats?
Did you just leave?
Yeah, you don't need to see it.
Did I outstat you?
No.
Then how come I don't see your stats?
What do you mean never?
Then why are you embarrassed?
Why are you embarrassed?
No, you might be insecure.
Oh, are you insecure?
Guys, look.
I'm top rank, guys.
I had all the degrees.
Alright.
Wanna do one more?
One more mission?
Alright, let's do one more mission.
Let's see.
The last new heist is...
Fear and greed.
Guess which one I have.
Which one?
Fear and greed.
Same.
Women are scary.
They are.
How do you even talk to...
the ladies anyway?
I don't know.
I just started doing the greedy.
You just started doing the greedy?
Yeah.
Let's go.
Hello.
Hello, ma'am.
Are you having a nice day?
Have a great evening, madam.
The fuck, dude?
What, you guys can do better?
You guys think you can do better?
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
I should have bought stuff.
Wait.
Go back to main menu.
I forgot to...
upgrade my stuff.
I was researching manipulation.
Yes.
Now I can be...
my dream come true.
Bro is manipulative.
Wait, how do I reset the skills?
E.
It doesn't let me reset it.
It doesn't let me reset all these skills.
I don't know.
What do you mean you don't know?
I mean, it worked for me.
It didn't work for me.
I want to buy manipulator.
No!
How can I manipulate now?
Manipulate them.
It says it's locked.
Oh, it resets the points and not the res...
Oh, my God.
I wasted my time.
I wasted...
How am I going to manipulate now?
I don't know.
How can I manipulate people?
Start drifting.
Anyway.
Do I start now?
No, I wanted to fucking take the cops as a hostage.
This fucking sucks.
I can't take the cops as a hostage.
All right.
I want to...
I don't know if I should buy a better main gun.
You know what?
This gun... Okay, what's the most expensive gun I can buy?
400k.
The R5.
All right.
I mean, this looks pretty cool.
This gun looks really cool.
You don't know what gun I'm holding, but like, it's really cool.
Okay.
It's really cool.
Okay, I got the muzzle brake and then I got nothing else on it because I'm not high enough level.
Wait, can I put stock?
No.
Wait, I am level 3.
What do you mean I have to unlock at level 7?
I am level 7.
The weapon.
Oh.
Yeah.
That makes a lot more sense now.
All right, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Wait, the knife is level 16.
God, that sucks.
I don't want level 16.
There's a knife?
Yeah.
No, the knife you use for your throw.
Oh.
Yeah, I have throwing knife for stealth.
Yeah, all right, I'm ready.
I'm ready for real.
Yeah, this is exactly why I got Tenjin because he actually knows what he's doing.
I have no clue what I'm doing.
That's why I was like, you know what?
Maybe I get my brother.
He's not only teaching me, he's not only teaching Chat, he's teaching the rest of us too.
Hey.
But yeah, if you guys want to try out the new Payday 3 updates, click on the link pinned in my chat and in the description below.
It really helps support the stream.
Also, like, huge shout out to Payday 3 for sponsoring us.
It really helps out a lot.
Guys, it helps Tenjin too because I dragged him into this.
I'm not even a contract, but all right.
What?
He's my plus one.
He got four exposure and he got the four exposure bucks and the free Payday.
Free Payday and an exposure.
Oh, man.
Thank you, Payday 3.
Thanks, Payday 3.
I'm ready.
Since we've hit John Conqu- what?
It's just gone.
I wish you could just read it for a while.
I know, I know what the lore is.
Thanks, Salmer.
Oh, is this the mall?
Oh, it's the stock market.
Stocks go up.
Numbers up.
Numbers, numbers, numbers.
Wait, we're not even...
Buy high, sell low.
Wait, you did stock market, right?
No, I...
Nothing happened.
No.
I hear nothing.
Wait, but weren't we at the radio?
Hey, we're going loud anyway.
Um...
Oh.
Yeah, hold on.
I'm choking this guy.
He's into it.
I'm doing lockpick.
I did it.
Okay.
And then, that's it.
There's nothing in this room.
I did the lockpick, but I don't know for what reason.
Wait, how many times can you answer the...
Oh, three radios.
Okay.
He's enjoying it, man.
What do you mean by that?
What are you doing to him?
I don't know.
Oh, shit.
What happened there?
Nothing.
Nothing's going on.
I hear there's nothing going on.
No, nothing's going on.
Can you answer the radio?
What did you do?
What did I do?
You shot him!
He was calling his colleagues.
Oh, what did I do?
Surely, your manipulative skill does not work on your coworkers.
Oh, yeah, yeah, Mr. I don't want to do stealth with you because every time I do stealth, I'm always able to do it successfully by myself.
Clearly, clearly, that's a fucking lie.
No, no, no.
Clearly, that's a fucking lie.
Where's the fucking zipline?
Where is the zipline?
Oh, wait, it's the elevator.
This one.
Power down the elevator.
Guys, it wasn't me.
It cannot be me, guys.
It cannot be me.
He didn't see me.
Tengen literally shot him.
If it was me, why did Tengen shot him?
If it was me, how come Tengen shot him?
I didn't even shoot him.
I was beating him up.
That makes it better?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How does that make it better?
How does it make it better?
I had to choke a guy for three minutes.
Okay, but like...
That makes it...
Sorry, I did not know you were into that.
He was into that.
And who was enabling his...
Where is the ship?
I don't know.
I'm doing this.
Fuck you now.
I don't even...
Oh, no.
They're here.
They're here now.
Where's the ship line?
I don't fucking know.
Okay, I got it.
Where was it?
It's in the fucking ventilation.
Oh, you had to go to the vent?
You got vented?
Yeah.
I...
Oh,
shit.
That's kinda sus, bro.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
It has to be to the right.
The one here.
Right?
Should be.
You, right?
You have to deactivate it, I think.
Oh, I actually shot it.
Is this?
There's only one elevator.
There's multiple.
Oh, wait.
Back there.
The one's back there.
What the fuck is this music?
Which one is the deactivated elevator?
Follow me.
Oh, shit.
I unlocked elevators right here.
That saxophone is fucking going crazy right now.
I found it.
I'm prying open.
I'm pulling it open.
Thanks for helping, guys.
Get the zipline.
Alright, I'm going down.
Cancel.
Okay.
Yes.
I saw that.
Civilians, get the fuck down.
Get the fuck down or I'm going to shoot you.
Get the fuck down.
Alright, I got him.
Oh, shit.
Wait, don't follow me.
We're manipulating the market.
Oh my god, let's go.
Let's go.
Go up.
No fucking way.
How are we going to get caught?
We're wearing masks.
We're literally wearing masks.
They will never know.
Oh my god.
We're going to save Concord, guys.
We're going to short Concord.
No, we can manipulate the numbers to go up for Concord and save it.
We can put Concord back in the market.
No, he can't be dead.
We can save Concord.
Why do I have a drill for this though?
Wait, is that the...
Oh, that's the CEO.
Hey man, the CEO needs to live.
Holy shit, look at his fucking office.
Oh, I can't even shoot.
Oh my god, he has his own coffee machine and everything.
This guy was bougie as fuck.
Let's see.
Holy shit.
That guy was so bougie.
There was like coffee machines.
His entire office is gold colored.
He has golden statues.
He has three, he has four, five monitors.
What is he going to do with five monitors?
Monitor the stocks?
That's literally the reason why people have a lot of them.
He can have one monitor, we can have at least two monitors with like three tabs.
No.
I'm beating the shit out of this piece of shit drill.
Oh, you're hammering it?
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
Hammer time.
Alright, nice.
I love how that just fixes everything.
Piece of shit drill.
Search the office for transaction files?
I guess like here.
I'm looking.
Look at the other one.
Oh my god, maybe I can find Concord.
Yeah, put them back in the store.
We gotta find Concord and put it back in the stock market, guys.
We're gonna save Concord.
We're gonna save Concord, guys!
There's hope.
There's actual hope.
Oh my god, surely one of them is Concord.
Surely, surely one of them is it.
I'm missing one more.
Oh, I found it.
One more Concord.
No, it's never too late, guys.
That's what stock market manipulation means.
This is exactly why I got into the business.
The business?
Yeah.
I got into the heist business so I could bring back Concord.
We're shorting it, though.
Okay, you're shorting it.
I'm fucking trying to save it.
Then why are you here?
What do you mean, shorting it?
Yeah, we're shorting it.
Wait, no, we're not.
No way, no, don't say that.
Top left.
Don't say that.
Get down!
No!
I actually almost shot him.
I almost shot him.
Oh shit.
Look at the margin.
No!
Look at the margin right there.
I wanted to save you!
I tried so hard.
I tried so hard to save Concord.
I thought I was gonna be the one.
Okay,
it's like right here.
Guys, I fucked up.
Guys, it's just you.
I messed up.
I messed up Tenjin.
Not the numbers!
Okay.
I got some medibags.
I got it.
I'm so sad.
I thought we could save Concord.
I thought there was hope.
There is.
No, we're shorting it.
That means all hope is lost.
Goodbye.
We're gone.
Oh, it's over here.
I just ate their donut.
I'm connecting.
Oh, you're connecting.
I can't believe it.
I knew I should have manipulated it hard enough.
I knew it.
Oh my god.
It's going down.
Yeah, activate the circuit breaker.
Where's the circuit breaker?
Oh, it's over here.
I'm heading over.
Don't worry, they're shooting you.
Sure.
Wait, how the fuck?
X4.
X4 is right here.
What the fuck are you looking at?
Right here.
How do you see that?
I'm seeing X's.
Oh, X4.
I knew that.
I'll keep looking at the...
I'll keep looking at the stock market.
I'll tell you the...
...circuit breaker.
Guys, it's going up.
Guys, I knew it.
We're saving Concord.
It's going up.
Look, Tengen is going up.
It's going up, Tengen.
Oh my god, I knew it.
We're saving it.
It's alive.
Oh my god, we're gonna...
Guys, it's possible.
Wait, what?
How did he not die?
I knew it.
I knew you guys.
I knew you guys were...
...were fucking with me.
I never gave up.
I never backed down.
What do you know?
I know the new Apex season is coming up.
In Tuesday.
I can't leak anything.
I have to wait until the 5th.
I actually...
I can't legally say anything.
I see.
I mean, I can tell you.
No, I cannot.
I signed a contract.
I knew it.
I can't, guys.
I can't have a good relationship...
...with Respawn.
All I'm saying is that...
Oh, sorry.
I was not paying.
It's 7455.
7455.
Next...
...circuit breaker.
A6.
Where is A6?
Guys, it's crazy though.
It's so crazy.
The new...
My only problem with Apex right now is just the time to kill.
Like, you think it's too long or too short?
Too long.
Too fucking long, man.
What?
Wait.
That's the wrong panel.
I'm not gonna say anything more.
That's a laugh of...
...something of the opposite, I think.
I see your laugh.
You're welcome.
I gave him a shoulder pain.
Oh, man.
That's...
...awkward.
That's so awkward.
The thing you don't like the most...
...is the time to kill.
That's so awkward.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Oh, man.
I guess you'll find out on Tuesday.
Surely, they won't add like a fucking...
You'll find out on Tuesday.
Surely, they won't add like a...
...six layer armor.
You'll find out on Tuesday.
Yippee!
I'm streaming it.
Of course, I was streaming the launch of Apex.
Toki, shut up.
I didn't say anything!
What did I say?
I didn't say anything.
She didn't say anything.
I got no fucking clue.
Yeah, he doesn't even know what's going on.
He doesn't even know what's going on.
He's so clueless.
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's 333.
No, that's the wrong code.
Oh, okay.
Which one is the code?
Right here.
I'm hacking it.
Shit.
What the fuck?
There's a security room right here.
Man, I wonder what happens if we were able to get that security room.
Oh, it's like the camera.
Yeah, a camera.
It's a disabled camera.
Ow, my armor just got chunked.
Holy fuck.
Oh, shit!
I was like, who's shooting me from behind?
Oh, we're cleaning your mess up, little guy.
I was like, I had a really bad obsession with Deadlock.
Because I realized that Seven is a more fun character to play in the end.
You play Seven?
Yeah, I used to play Abrams.
Because Surefour taught me Abrams.
And it was like the character I knew how to play.
And then I learned how to play Seven.
I did that because I hated the game.
I was not enjoying the game playing Abrams.
And then one of my friends was like, oh, you should try out Seven.
You might like Seven more.
So then I played Seven and I was so fucking obsessed with Seven.
But it's also because it was Pew Pew, right?
And then I was trying to be like, oh, come on guys, let's play Deadlock.
I want to play, I want to play.
I would be begging people to play Deadlock with me so I can play Seven.
But at one point, no one was online.
And I was like, you know what?
I'm going to solo queue Seven.
I want to do it.
And now I don't like Deadlock anymore.
Yeah.
That happens.
And now I beat the addiction.
Did you put Seven in high priority?
Yeah, yeah, the highest priority.
Like the purple one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That explains why it's shit.
Wait, why?
I don't know.
I just feel like every time I put a hero in high priority, it's so shit.
Because people are like, oh, you took my Seven.
Oh, oh.
And they're playing like they're not main characters.
So they're like, oh, you took Seven.
Oh.
I got like three games.
And two games of that were people crying that I took their Seven.
And stuff.
So then like, obviously people were playing super fucking...
That's a thing?
Yeah, people were like crying about it.
But anyway, anyway.
I stopped playing Deadlock after that.
Because I was like, this game is shit.
I beat the addiction after that.
Yeah.
It's only fun when you're playing with other people.
I found out.
Yeah.
It's not fun solo queue.
Wait, what's Chainz doing?
Oh, sorry.
7472.
Wait, what's 7472?
No, 7470.
You do it?
No, enter it, enter it.
Did you enter it?
I haven't.
Oh, I got you.
I'm covering.
Uh-huh.
Are you getting your ass kicked?
Yeah.
You had a feeling.
Like he just dropped in a hatch.
Yeah, I was gonna be like, where did he come from?
There was no openings.
Drones.
Fuck.
Goddamn drones.
No!
Oh, God!
This is why the game failed.
We were the reason why the game failed.
Yeah, we shut down a market.
We shut down Concord.
It was us all along!
Oh, my God!
Yes, it was.
It was us all along!
I've become the villain.
If you live long enough to become the villain.
No!
It was me.
I wanted to save Concord and I ended up shutting down their entire offices.
Oh, hey.
There's armor here.
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Oh, it's this thing.
Alright, we'll shut down a market.
Timeline save.
We were actually secret time travelers.
We traveled back in time to make sure Concord failed.
It was us all along!
We made sure it was a canon event.
Boom.
Everything was on red on the screen.
Holy shit.
It went from green to red.
That wasn't going to do nothing.
We have to get back to the roof.
While we're doing that.
Right here.
It was us.
That's right, chat.
It was us all along!
Up we go.
Say thank you to me.
We could have done anything else with our time traveling abilities.
Instead, we shut down Concord.
It was just much more important.
Wait, here?
Oh, here.
I found it.
He's behind a door.
Give me a break.
He waited there for like three hours.
He's like, eventually he's going to show up.
Thank god it was a canon event.
Alright.
Replace it.
I got a satellite dish.
Okay.
We made our own.
We're fucking engineers, apparently.
We made our own fucking satellite dish.
Yeah, because everything is on an EMP.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, we have to guard it now.
Oh my god, we're almost safe.
We're installing Wi-Fi right now.
We're desperate.
Guys, even heist robbers need Wi-Fi.
Next time, next time we save Harambe.
Yeah, we'll save Harambe.
We were the ones that took the shot.
Yeah, yeah.
We were the ones who shot him.
We were the ones that took the shot.
No!
Now you know how I felt when I wanted to save Concord.
It was a canon event.
You can't avoid it.
Tenjin was the kid.
He was the bait.
And I was the one with the rifle.
It was me, baby.
It was me.
Yeah, finish the sentence.
Finish the sentence.
You know exactly how it goes.
Tenjin, finish this.
How does it go?
How does it go, Tenjin?
Yes, I do.
I do know how it goes.
Do I?
Do I know how it goes?
Jesus Christ, is he still alive?
He's still alive!
Oh my God, he's running!
This
guy!
I'm so dead.
I'm actually so dead.
Okay.
Did we fix it?
Boom.
There we go.
I fixed it.
I'm like one HP.
I'm dead.
I think I have one more life.
I do not have armor.
Does any of our guys have armor?
I don't know.
Oh my God, please.
Oh, readjust the crane's position?
Yeah, I readjusted.
Holy shit, hurry the fuck up.
This is the slowest crane known to man.
Oh my God.
What's going on?
Guys, please.
I need to use the Wi-Fi.
I'm going through withdrawals right now.
I know.
I broke my armor.
Well...
I think you might have to clutch this yourself, Tengen.
I'm not doing so well.
Oh, Mr. Stark.
I'm not feeling so good.
The crane's here.
Mr. Stark, I don't feel so well.
Mr. Stark, what if I die from doing this job?
You're alive.
Here.
Use this.
Wait, where did you...
Why did you not put this out sooner?
Why did you not...
No, you're fine.
Oh my God, we did it.
We did it!
We did it.
We're gamers.
Let's go!
We're out of here.
Oh my God.
Easy.
Easiest game of my life.
We did it.
Concord is no more.
We made sure Concord failed.
Sadly, it was a canon event.
My hero.
Except Harambe.
We gotta make sure he stays down.
Yes.
Still is.
That was fun though.
That was fun checking out the first year anniversary.
It was.
Yeah, it definitely...
It's a lot different, right?
From when it first came out.
Yes.
A lot different.
Yeah, so if you guys didn't know, for the first year anniversary, they updated a lot.
A lot of stuff to it.
Like Tenjin said, there's new server browsers, new UI, a lot of new updates to it.
Graphic-wise, UI-wise, even the voice.
In-game voice was updated a lot as well.
We tested it out and it was pretty good.
But yeah, huge shout-out to Pay...
I almost said PayPal.
Huge shout-out to PayPal 3.
To PayDay 3 for sponsoring me.
So please, if you want to support the stream, if you want to support PayDay, click on the link on my description or pin in the chat.
Anyway, also thank you to Tenjin for playing with me today on a sponsored stream.
I appreciate it.
We tried to find two more people, but like, we didn't.
The time was short.
It was very short.
We were like, who do we get?
And Tenjin was like, I don't fucking know my brother.
And then I was like, fuck it.
But then apparently his brother had to add classes and stuff.
Who do we get?
We have to make it look like we have to get people so we look like we know what we're doing.
We need to find people that knows how to play PayDay and like, you know, make us look like this game is super fun because it is.
And...
It is.
It was really fun.
You saw it yourself, guys.
Yeah, it was very fun.
The new missions.
There's a lot of new missions and story stuff to it now, too.
But yeah, thanks Tenjin for coming over and trying it out with me.
And I hope you enjoy your free PayDay DLC.
I will.
But yeah, guys, I'm gonna go talk to my chat real quick now, Tenjin, but thank you again for stopping by.
I really appreciate it.
I'll see you later.
I'll see you later, man.
I got place to be.
Alright.
Take care now.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Alright, guys.
Yeah, again, thank you for Tenjin for coming by.
Like, it was very short notice getting him involved because I was like, I don't want to do this solo.
I was like, I don't know.
I feel like...
I don't...
I'm not very well versed in PayDay 3 in general compared to Tenjin.
So I was like, I don't want to do this alone.
I feel like if I should...
I should...
get someone that knows what they're doing.
And so I'm really glad that Tenjin was available to play with me.
And yeah, and again, thank you again to PayDay 3.
It's really crazy to be sponsored by PayDay 3.
I remember watching PayDay playthroughs from UberHacks or Nova growing up and, like, UberHacks or Nova and, like, ImmortalHD watching, like, PayDay playthroughs from them.
Like, from the creatures because I remember they used to sponsor the creatures a lot back then and they had, like, special promotions with them and everything.
So, like, it's really crazy to see myself being sponsored by PayDay 3 as well.
So, like, it's just really crazy to think about.
Like, I watched PayDay 1 people play PayDay 1 growing up and then now I'm sponsored by PayDay 3.
Like...
I've been getting so many sponsors lately and it really does help a lot that you guys support me and support the sponsors as well.
Because it lets me get more sponsors in general, too.
So, it really does help a lot.
So, yeah, huge shoutout to PayDay for sponsoring me and, like, it's very surreal to see it.
Anyway, guys, I'm sorry for being late.
I came back early.
I even came back early to make sure that, like, I would be on time today.
Like, because I always try to be on time for sponsors.
I was like, alright, got it.
And then...
I left my phone at the Uber.
I'm so sorry.
I literally can't do anything.
I couldn't stream without my phone.
And so...
I really appreciate you guys sticking it out.
I really appreciate you guys, like, sticking it out and, like, being here.
Even though that happened.
I really appreciate it.
That's actually the first time.
That was the very first time I forgot my phone.
I've never had that happen before.
I've never forgotten my phone before.
This is the very first time my mind has been so scattered.
Bro, the hotpot was so good.
They had, like, live noodle making.
They would make noodles for you and then it was so good.
You don't understand.
I spent $150 on hotpot.
It was so good.
And then I bought bath bombs.
I was like, today's your day, Doki.
It's your day.
Little do I know, it was not my day.
It was not my day in the end.
MrBrokenBot, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Hoping this covers the pain and torment of leaving your phone, Doki.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
You spent $170.
Oh, yeah.
And then I forgot my phone.
And then the Uber driver fucking blackmailed me for my phone.
I was desperate.
I was so desperate.
Thank you.
Thank you for the soup.
I am gonna call it here.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
If you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
This week is a lot of collabs.
I'll try to balance it out with some solo streams.
But...
The rest of the stuff is crazy.
Tomorrow, there's gonna be a big announcement regarding the rest stuff.
So, I know it's gonna be in the rest kingdoms for a while now, but there's gonna be a big announcement regarding the rest stuff.
If you guys know how the rest events on Twitch goes, you might have an idea what this announcement is.
But anyway, guys, I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.